This episode of Your Mom's house is
brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress,
the only online mattress company that
provides free delivery set up and mattress
removal.
[inaudible]
here it is.
Thank you Landon.
Believe Landon sent in this instrumental.
We always love receiving your
instrumentals and your original songs.
Honestly, it's been one of the highlights
for me of doing the show for years.
I love playing the songs. I
loved playing instrumentals. A,
here's what's going on in
the rest of this month.
I only have two shows left this month.
Uh,
two big shows they are going to
be in Fresno and Bakersfield,
California. Nine A. Um, they are,
there's about a hundred
tickets left in Bakersfield.
Quite a few more available in Fresno.
Uh,
that's October 26th and 27th go to
time square.com tour page for that next
month. Uh, the only shows
left with tickets are, uh,
Fort Myers to bark Myers November 1st.
The next day.
I'm in Jacksonville,
Florida at the Florida theater
and there are 70 tickets left.
Uh, Orlando is all sold out. Augusta
has about a hundred tickets left.
That's November 4th. Uh,
the rest of November,
I'm in Montclair.
There's only tickets available
for the Wednesday show.
And in fill her up Delphia I'm doing
four shows at the Merriam theater.
The only show available with
tickets is Friday late show.
Uh,
from there you can go to [inaudible] dot
com slash tour look at the 2019 first
half of the year dates.
We just added a second shows
in Houston and San Francisco.
Those are both in January. We added second
shows. The first shows are sold out.
A second shows have been added in a
number of other cities. San Diego, Dallas,
Medford, DC, Chicago,
Tampa, Oklahoma City.
We're about to announce
two more coming up, but uh,
get on it while you
can and I thank you so,
so much for your support on that.
Very exciting to have a
tour kickoff like that.
Jean Jean,
I too will be touring in 2019.
I'm going to be announcing
those dates very soon here.
But first catch my new special.
The degenerates is
going to air on Netflix,
starting air stream going
like 500 years old. Um,
October 30th. It's going to start
streaming on Netflix. Check that out.
You're your homie. Joey Diaz is on
there as well as big Jay Oakerson Jay,
we got yama, Saunders,
Sanders, Sanders. Um,
why can't I remember the other wonderful
girls names Lisa Trager. Very blurry.
Yeah. And that's it. Check
it out. We found it in Vegas.
So before I start touring,
I'm going to run this hour
locally here in Los Angeles.
And the very small you who
room at flip hairs comedy club.
There's really just a handful of tickets.
I like to do these small
shows before I go out.
So that's going to be on October 21st
that's this Sunday at flappers in the
[inaudible] room.
And then October 28th the following
Sunday in the u who room get your tickets,
Christina, be online. San Diego.
November 24th I've added a late show
at the house of grooves. Come see me.
Get out of the house during Thanksgiving.
Fill her up.
Delphia second show added December 7th
get your tickets to the late show as well
as the late show,
Gramercy theater in Jude or
titties on the 8th of December.
And I'm going to be announcing 2019
dates very soon. Christina p online.
Thank you. God bless. Alright,
there it is. I like Jean.
I lie, get jeans. Thank you guys so much
to the show.
Thank you for supporting our live shows,
supporting our
good immersion method.com/tom Segura.
There's a bunch of new stuff
we have exciting holiday
stuff that's coming out in
a couple of weeks. I believe. I should
probably check to see if the new,
the new hat is up.
There it is. It's there.
It's the gene beanie. Look, Gee, I
know I saw it today. It's just models.
So awesome. The gene or the gene?
That Hoodie, my favorite Hoodie.
So this is our winter hat or a beanie.
That's so fun.
I love it. I love it. I love a good
beanie. I know. You know I love what Ilan,
Ethan brought us the state
going to and I like that one.
I'm going to ask that they send us some
of these so we can wear them. Yeah,
it's the best for winter times
when it gets cold outside.
Put on. You're barely keeping
it together here in Los Angeles.
Actually love those cool mornings.
My mother used to say is crispy outside.
Please be and go.
I don't think it's crispy, mom. Well,
you ready to do this? Oh my God,
I'm so, so much to share,
to share. Let's get going.
Here we go and pool your jeans up.
You don't even do it except for
who is Randy.
Well, we'll go. We'll
go to your mom's house.
It's here on another
episode of Your Mom's house
so you know what to do. Drop
your genes and rob. Rob,
did you just come up with it?
Yeah.
How long did it take you to think of that
one in a second here. Really good time.
Thanks. Do you think this
lady is not well? You know,
it's really crazy when you see
somebody like her who looks like it's,
she's on the edge of complete breakdown,
saying come absolute nonsense to this
poor truck driver that look on her face is
terrifying. Sure. Uh, it's
that she's driving, right?
How does it drive it?
Drive now they have licenses.
They walk among us like normal people.
I know. I think about that all the time.
This show has informed my opinion
of the mass is so much more.
I know that people like this. I mean,
God bless her. I'm not trying to,
I mean, you know, I don't
want to say that like, uh,
it's hilarious that she's super sick.
Sure.
But that guy just say that my mom
was crazy and it provided a lot of
entertainment, like we were saying before.
Yeah. She'd be like, it's cold outside.
It's crispy. I have a lot of crazy
crap. A lot of crazy in my opinion. Yes.
But what I'm saying
is, but sometimes I, I,
I think about how many people out there
and especially on the road, oh yeah.
Are really sick and like
shouldn't be driving nuts.
My Dad used to say it all the time.
Everybody is crazy or on drugs.
It's pretty accurate. Now
I'm like, I think he's right.
I think one of the things you'll
end up telling our boys a lot.
All of like the two of us yeah.
Is like,
you're going to navigate a world
of crazy. Yeah, absolutely.
Just be prepared for
unreasonable people out there.
That's what, there's a lot of out there.
I prepared her constantly. Now your,
or hopefully the boys are, but like
a lot of times if you're not crazy,
you're expecting not or you're expecting
crazy people to be able to reason with
you. That's right. And that's the big
mistake. That's my biggest flaw. That's,
can I tell you something?
It took,
it took me 36 years as an adult and an
end 10 years of therapy to realize that
you can't reason with crazy.
So that's a huge life lesson.
It is a huge life lesson.
There's,
I'm almost 40 and that's something that
I've recently come to terms with, right?
That you can't rationalize with
totally fucking greedy people,
but you can have a good
time watching them.
You could have a fun podcast about them.
And you know, like I, like I said,
I love my mother. I'm just my,
I'll say it again. And for those you just
tuning in. My mother was mentally ill,
she a borderline personality disorders,
schizophrenia.
Later in life I got an ass load
of crazy growing up. So, hey man,
don't fucking email me and tell
me how insensitive I am. Uh,
making fun of this shit cause I'm
entitled to do that. Okay. That's true.
Now her point about truckers being not
so sexed up, I don't know much about,
I mean, listen, I know a lot of people
who drive trucks listened to our show.
God bless him.
I love him.
Now my understanding is
truckers are the nastiest.
I mean they have a nasty reputation.
Say there's probably some really
good wholesome truckers out there.
Of course family are the,
they do have a rep for
getting lizard lots. Right.
And, and you know, being the dirty guys,
but I think if some of them are probably
very decent people, most are sure.
But then there's things
like you hear about,
we'll let you have a joke in your act
about going to a certain vent in place.
Video plays and there's holes in walls.
That's primarily, from what I understand,
like truckers. Yeah. I mean that was
on a high way in Carolina and yeah,
it probably,
yeah, it probably was, uh, uh,
frequented by some truckers. Yeah.
Well, I'd like to, locals were welcome.
I mean they didn't have a policy.
I mean she, she said some real crazy shit
here to the shirt. She says a lot more,
but I'll, I'll just replay it so you
get an idea. Oh boy, that was weird.
She
Warner
she's having a like a vision right now.
Yeah. Yup, Yup, Yup. Four Times. That's a,
that's not a, it's not a lot, but how
did she know it was for, she knows,
she sees that
God said a truck to the side of the road.
Yeah.
I wonder if,
cause my mom too when towards the end of
her life got into Jesus and the Bible.
Yeah. Like I, when we
went there and stuff,
there was a lot of leg underlining
highlighting the Bible and like she'd have
these religious cards kind
of stashed everywhere.
I guess that seems like a pretty common,
that's a lot.
It happens a lot when they
know it will go nutty. Yeah.
So it just went like, I have a
like an atheist relative. Yeah.
Who when he got sick and
he was very much like,
not into religion and everybody around
because he knew it was going to die,
start talking like he knew, he knew it
was gonna, he was gonna die. They're like,
just get back on the
time to start hedging the bet.
And then he's like, all right.
He started to pray and stuff, you know,
it has been, you know, makes sense.
So you may as well try, like if
it's, if all that stuff's true. Yeah.
I mean it'll be on the right side of
it. Yeah. Makes Sense. Yeah. I mean, I,
I understand why somebody who,
they're like, you're about to die.
Do you want to just go ahead
and ask JC if he'll take,
then you probably go like, yeah, all
right. I should believe in Jesus.
Now there was that famous writer
who was, uh, an atheist who was, uh,
diagnosed and you know, told he
was terminal and he did, he died.
No, no, no, no. He's a scientist.
I'm talking about this writer,
a writer who's the most famous, I can't,
I'm drawing a blank on them right now.
And they were like, how about now that
you know you're going to die? He was like,
Nah, he still stayed on. He was
like, go fuck yourself. Yeah.
Well start respect to shit. That was Carl
Sagan on his deathbed. They go, are you,
do you not believe in God anymore?
He's like, Nah, Bro, I'm fucking,
I'm ride or die atheist all
the way, homie. All the way.
He did the double bird double Burt's.
Yeah.
I gave him the double bird.
He was like, Look Dad Shit
homie. Yeah, go to prison,
prison going to hell.
And I respect it.
I respect the shit out of being like,
no,
I'm not buying it. I'm not,
you know, I used to buy it.
I bought it as a kid and the older I get,
the less I believe it.
Especially since having children
of my own where I'm like,
there's nothing out there.
It is lawless.
It is a ruthless world of nature is
a jungle and you just got to get,
I think it's,
I think the big thing about religion
is that it's very comforting to people.
Sure is. I, which I, you know,
you can't criticize that.
If it makes you feel sure it's meaning
and gives you come from like I get it.
But uh, yeah. Can I tell you what
really made me think about, yeah.
How there's no, God is watching
that space movie with Ryan Gosling.
My God. We went to see the,
what's it called? It's called
Ryan got us to the moon.
Ryan Gosling shouldn't wear a shirt.
It's called,
why the fuck did they put him
in a fucking astronaut outfit?
That's why I go see Ryan Gosling.
So as he shirtless at some point
and he wasn't even shirtless,
he looked like a regular guy. It was
so upsetting. It's called first man,
first man to shit.
And on the moon.
What one of the big flaws we went
to see first man, by the way,
I was ready to leave a few minutes in.
I'm serious.
Stupid. I'm serious. You looked
over at me. I was, it was, no,
it was like an hour in and I was like,
all right, it's all set up. I get it.
Let's go. I know what's going to
happen is I know it's going to happen.
I know he's going to land on the moon
is going to walk on the moon. I know.
I've seen it. Boring. Boring is
exactly right and I was like,
find aliens that we didn't hear
about before. That wouldn't be none.
The MTV flag was up there. There's some,
it's movies. There's, this is a big thing.
Movies about things you
already know about. That's
tough. I know. It is tougher.
Like that's fucking boring. Newspaper
one we saw, oh my God, that was terrible.
What's her name? The one I love, you know,
she's a fan to everyone's a good heroin.
Meryl Streep.
That's what kept me from falling asleep
is at least they had good accuracy.
The Post, I think it was us. Jesus.
What a boring fucking movie that was.
How many awards did that piece of
Shane as directed by Spielberg?
Spielberg and it,
you know,
it hit the blueprint of
movie making movie solid.
It's a solid movie in that it follows,
here's the setup,
here's the, you know, the
controversy, here's the resolution.
But you see every scene coming.
You see every line coming. I mean,
there's no surprise in that movie,
which is what makes movies fucking boring.
You know what the story is and we
all know what happened with, uh,
what's his name? Lance Armstrong.
When he went to the man. Yeah, man.
Lance landed there on his bike and
then he gets off and he's like,
so what if I cheated and he puts a
flag in the moon. Everybody knows,
everybody knows what,
whatever.
Here's the things that I find
very upsetting about the movie.
Ryan Gosling wears a shirt.
He wears a shirt. He fucking,
so they show him peeing on the spacecraft,
which is cool.
Finally we got to see how they learn
and it's a pisses and he shuts and he's
like, I pissed. And then, and
it was brown. He goes, oh,
there's so much nitrogen in the
air. And I was like, oh, that makes,
that makes sense. No
shitting. And it's like, okay,
these guys are up in space
for four days to get to them.
That I could take a dump the whole time.
Okay. That's upsetting. Well, I'm serious.
Like I know we joke about it on the show.
I know serious shit and space.
They don't tell you and especially do
they eat like Mras like they do in the
military to kind of block you up.
That's interesting. Also also,
they don't show the guys jacking off at
all or even talking about it like you
know they're, they're thinking about,
of course there's no porn. Of course.
They're like,
what do you need when you're up there?
Obviously that'd be like a top three list.
You know,
if they'd probably be like, oh,
we need fluids to drink the food.
I want music, I want to watch some
porn. I would rearrange that list.
If you were going in his face
first is porn, then food,
then liquid.
I Dunno if that's the order,
but I just feel like it's very misleading.
Once again,
Hollywood misleads us into thinking that
there's no jacking off going on in any
facet of life for any type of character.
There's no poop and going on ever.
I mean it's like, well, two,
two guys is why people are not
going to the movies anymore.
Two guys alone in space and nobody's
jerking off. I know. I don't buy it.
I think they're both like, how about a
jerk you off and then I'll check you off.
And then they watch the come float
around because there's no grass and
buzz
buzzes a deck.
And I actually wanted to hear him talk
more. It was an asshole in the movies.
It's interesting. Uh, but here's
my point is I saw that and I,
here's the amazing part
about the moon landing,
which you don't think about as
a kid when you hear about it.
It was done in the 60s and when you
think about the level of technology that
existed in the 1960s
we barely had toasters,
refrigerators, blenders, all that
shit was new. They didn't even have a,
you don't have a fucking
cell phone and these dudes,
it's all dudes put dudes on the moon and
you know how many men died to get there,
which is pretty crazy part in the movie.
I didn't know that there.
I assumed obviously,
you know,
there's a whole program going
on for years to lead up to this.
I didn't realize how many people died.
No.
And how people didn't like the space
program because of it and tested it.
A fire
in one of the space craft before it
even launched, like a test day signed.
The three guys died before
it ever even took off.
Cause the fire just spoiler alert.
Well it's not really its history but um,
but that's when you realize stuff
like yeah, there, there is no god.
I mean there's no god.
You see him take steps on the moon.
It feels like you are doing it,
which is so amazing with this movie guys.
Go and see it. Uh, I just uh, when they,
when they finally show him taking his
first steps and you feel like your doing
it the way that it's shot,
it's just brilliant. Brilliant.
Damien Chazelle uh,
Scott or Josh singer and James Hansen,
the director and the writers.
Here's the question everybody has for
you guys. Right. Where is the company?
This movie is missing a big
portion of interest from us.
I'm being serious though when
they have to Brown. Yeah.
Cause it was there like a flap in
the back, like old timey pajamas,
you know like the poop,
the poop shoot flat cartoon pajamas.
Is that how the they do it?
Well maybe we don't know.
We don't know cause these guys decided
to get lazy and not tell us anything.
Yeah. And again, I'm bummed that Ryan
Gosling kind of look like a regular guy.
Like they live in light them all nice.
And he looked like a totally normal dude.
Yeah. It was upsetting. No body
shots. No. Yeah, none. I was thinking,
because what I heard before we went to
the movie was that there was a scene
where he's on a couch on all fours and
that he took his wife's head and he put
it behind and forced her to,
you know,
he described service from behind. Yeah.
That'd be a cool scene. I heard that too.
That that's how he was
chosen for the space program.
Do you think Eva Mendez Itas
crumb was Ryan Gosling Nasty,
nasty as hell. Why you think she's
so nasty? They got two kids too.
I think they do. She just looks kinda
nasty. Oh my gosh. Does nasty things.
Really? She looked like she
down. Hmm. I don't know.
You tell me you're the one that
bangs hose loves her. I mean,
you're the one who's always like
Ryan Gosling, Ryan Gosling Creek.
I'd lick his butt hole. I
would, he looks on selling.
Do you think that she does if,
yeah,
if he's his hairless as I think
he is and he looks really clean.
He just looks like he smells nice all
the time. Yeah, I would, I would do it.
Just how rob,
you know how Robin Wright Penn has that
air of her that she's really clean and
that her butthole, is it Robin Wright
Penn's still or just running right?
Probably just Robin Wright and she
looks like her butthole doesn't smell.
What is it? That shit come
back. I know. How so far?
How's The forest with no Kevin
Spacey to kill dummy. Here it goes.
Your career shit bag. God Man. Savage. Oh,
that's the price you paid the
price you pay for being dudes. Um,
speaking of touching dudes,
there's no segue for that. But, uh,
well we have a lot of updates
in the cigarette household.
Should we finish this clip first? Oh,
I didn't know it was not finished.
I just want to get to work
days before guests come
specious ladies making.
Okay.
[inaudible]
know. It kind of reminds me of, yeah,
that sounds like him when
he gives these speeches.
It's really off of his lithium.
Right.
Well he said he just stopped taking
his medication. Oh yeah. Yeah,
she definitely did too.
Yeah,
that's the problem my mom refused to
take stuff to and that's when things had
southware.
Yeah,
I thought they were going to spell it out.
Like Electric Company.
She's still checking or song.
Oh Man. Yeah. That is
really unfortunate. Mm hmm.
Speaking of scrum, here's a message
we got. Hey Tim and crystal.
I have been with my girlfriend
for just over eight months now.
At one month I asked her what her favorite
thing in the bedroom was and she said
getting her scrum licked
as an ass eating virgin.
I was excited to try it out and we
both love it. Fast forward a week.
She asked me in the shower if I
would like to have my scrum licked.
This was a huge curve ball is I was not
prepared for an instantly declined at a
politeness because as a man I don't
have the prettiest asshole every day was
I pondered what it could possibly
feel like if she likes it so much,
then why would nine two one two months
went by of me thinking about it.
Just about every day I finally asked
her to dive in what we were showering.
It truly changed my life. Hands
down. The best feeling ever.
Nine months in our relationship
is stronger than ever and
I really believe it is
because of ass eating.
The fact that crystal has not eaten
Tim's ass saddens me and I cannot stand
listening to her,
the climate every time it's brought up.
A couple of days ago I asked her the Ftt
RTD question and she would not turn me
in. I believe her answer is a
direct correlation to eating my ass.
So Timmy,
if you want to change Crystal's answer,
you have to start with
her eating your app.
Thanks from Canada's national
capitol. Oh really? Interesting.
Ottawa, Ottawa. Yeah. Well
that's a interesting, okay.
It's just theory. Yeah. I just
think got to get in there.
Yeah. Um, somebody a asked
a couple episodes back.
This is an email,
a few episodes back.
You talked about due to like to have their
ball squeeze during sex and wondering
exactly what the turn was.
Well, I am one of those guys.
My wife knows that I like it when she
grabs my sack and just gradually squeezes
harder and harder and kill.
I can't take it anymore.
Part of it is pleasure and
pain and the other part of it,
what makes it a huge turn on is just
that this person who was about 75 pounds
lighter than me is
completely controlling me.
I will literally do anything she asks
me to do because my balls are completely
at her mercy. For some reason, that gets
me going like nothing else. My wife,
who probably was super confused the first
time I took her hand and squeezed it
down on my nuts now realizes what power
she has and is also totally into it.
Unrelated note.
She was also not a ride or die wife.
Like how's he murdered a Barista?
He returned my swollen ball asking
to the police without second thought.
That's Nate from Milwaukee.
Get Ne. That's nice. Well,
I'm glad that that does shed some
light on the, uh, experience here.
It's makes sense.
It's kind of a power thing and he
likes that vulnerability of it.
Makes Sense. Yeah. Sorry, are you saying
you want me to squeeze your nuts tonight?
Uh, I okay. Yeah, that's
what saying. Sure. Yeah.
Who's that? There you go.
It's time for that. Yup. Oh,
genes. All right, here we go. Uh,
oh gosh. You know what? I did, sorry.
Talk for a second. I got to find it. Okay.
I'll talk for a second.
I did the wrong thing.
I'm very much looking forward to this
unplanned thing that you told me will
happen tonight now. So I'm pretty
much very much appreciate it. Okay.
Um, so we've had a really
interesting couple of days,
really months with this dog. Oh,
stop it. I hate that dog right now.
I love her again when I fucking hated her.
I know this dog has pretty
much once a month had diarrhea,
but we tell them the neatest part about
the Cayenne and what time it happens.
Yeah. It's always between like
two and four in the morning. Yeah.
Never any other time.
The need part is that you have the
ability to sleep through everything. Yeah,
I do.
You sleep through baby's crying,
but it's not selective dogs
having diarrhea. Sleep. You
can't get mad at anyone,
but I'm the one that has to
deal with the goddamn dog.
Here's the cool thing that
happened the other day. Kills me.
So a lot of times the older
boy who's two and a half, uh,
he'll pop up in the middle of the night,
stand in his crib and just
like yell or cry. You know, I,
I assume he's had a nightmare
or he's just awake, you know,
found himself awake and
wants to be comforted.
So typically I go downstairs at that
time and it will be anywhere from 1130 at
night to five o'clock in the morning.
It's just, it's just whenever,
it's not every night, but it's, you know,
it's semi regularly eventful evenings
and around. So the other night it's,
uh,
it's about five in the morning and he
starts screaming and I hear him on the
Monitor and so sit up and I'm like,
God damn.
Cause I was in a deep
sleep. I know. All right.
I go downstairs and I like how you go.
Like I know I'll always,
yeah, I look like, I like how
you're upset that I slept subset,
that you get to sleep. Such a selfish
person. But anyways, I go down there,
I pick them up Iraq, um, you
know, I call him him. He,
he gets relaxed in 10 seconds,
so relax.
And then I just stay with him for a
few minutes. I'm like, all right buddy,
we gotta go back to sleep. And
he's like, okay, put them back in,
walk upstairs and you know, you're,
you're more awake than you want to be.
Cause it's like five now. And I'm
like, fuck, I gotta go back to sleep.
And as I'm walking in,
I walk in the bedroom,
I'm walking to the bathroom,
so I'm going to brush my teeth before
I go back to bed. As I'm walking there,
I smelled like there is shit
and this room right now.
So you go like, how's fuck you're in
bed. You're like, how's Ellis? I'm like,
there's shit in the room right
now. And you're like, what?
And I go turn on the light.
You turn the line on.
The dog was just so, so
odd. It was horrible.
Had Shit on the like put her ass up to
the edge of the crate and slept and shit
through the crate.
Now for a long time our dogs,
shit or shit slept with us in bed.
But during the pregnancy it was like so
disruptive to your sleep that we just,
we have, you know, dog beds,
they like it in there. It's not,
or not hurting anything. So
the dog though, this is odd,
you had actually heard her moving around.
So here's the thing,
I was up at 2:00 AM pumping my tits,
so 3:00 AM I hear her.
She never actually asked
to be let out of the crate,
which she does is she just kind of sniffs.
She'll be like,
like she'll breathe a little
weirdly and she'll kind of like, ah,
like make like a yawning
stress. Yawn sound. Yeah.
And that's how I know it's time
to let her out. She doesn't act,
she never paused at the crate.
So it's a very subtle sounds that if I
don't hear them it can be fucking really
bad. So I heard the sounds
at three in the morning,
I walk over to her and I'm like,
do you want to go potty girl?
Do you want to go potty? And she looked
at me like, bitch, why did you wake me up?
Like she did not want to go potty. So that
I thought great. I went back to sleep,
heard Ellis pop up and then you
came back and she fucking shit.
She stuck her ass like you said. And not
just any shit. This is the neat part.
Yeah it is dog diarrhea.
It's so,
it's like liquid mushy shit.
And she did it in two corners of the
crazy sad and the other dog is like,
beef is like bitch,
the fuck are,
you can tell he's backed up.
Yeah. He's like Nah. Yeah.
When I opened the door he
hops out like over her shit.
So then we like again, at this point
it's like five 15 in the morning.
We get gloves late. I got the
whole setup, the latex glove,
garbage bags, spray spray. It's
fucking horrible man wipes.
And so we're cleaning trash bags,
diarrhea, shit at five 15 in the morning.
So we, I wrap up the dog bed that's
covered in shit throwing trash bucket.
We finally get like the shit in a bag.
And as I'm standing like, like all
right, now let's go back to bed.
The fucking smoke alarm, smoke
detector goes off downstairs. Yeah.
So I run downstairs. Am I trying to
find which smoke detectors going off?
It's in our older boys' room. Oh my
God. So I opened the door and it smells,
it smells like burning
rubber burning. Right. Smells
smoky. Yeah. And so I'm like,
Oh shit. And before, I mean,
I grab him and before I even turn around,
you're already like,
hell yeah. You're like, yeah,
at the house right now, Dude,
within a couple of minutes,
firefighter, you know what I say?
I call the fire department and I was like,
get over here right now.
I got two babies in this house.
Something's on fire. Hurry up, hurry up.
And there'll, and I'm never called the
fire department in my life. So I was like,
this is crazy. And I told him, I got two
babies, I got two babies. You gotta hurry,
you gotta hurry. And
they're like, well ma'am,
get the babies out of the house right now.
So of course we gather up the babies,
we're going out to the porch. But
it was amazed. They showed up.
I showed up quickly, so fast. It's
amazing. Fire Department. I mean,
firefighters are just amazing
people. But, and there
came full alarms. Oh, sirens,
fire firetrucks like trucks,
the paramedic ambulance,
and then the fire truck van all show up.
These guys come storming in with axes.
Yeah, I mean, and they were Jews there.
They were ready to go. They're
like, where's the fire? And anyways,
within seconds they calm
down and they're like,
does your heat just run
for like the first time?
And yeah,
it's a new heater and we just had it up
to then and then the fire guy goes, well,
it's because it's brand new and it's
burning off all the residue and stuff in
there. It's, it's an Hvac situation. Yeah.
I was so embarrassed and I'm standing
here in my jammies and I'm like,
I'm so sorry. I was, I was outside
showing a Ellis the fire truck.
I was like looking at the lights and
he was like, oh, oh, oh. He loved it.
You loved it. That was the coolest
thing ever that he woke up to do that.
I was mortified,
but I wouldn't have called had the
alarm in my son's room not gone off. No.
It's scary to,
in the moment,
it's also five o'clock in the morning
and your brain's kind of scrambling.
You don't know what's happening.
The next thing that happened was they
left and then now it's like five 45 yeah.
And then our kid is like, can
we play now? And I was like,
I know you were going back to bed.
And he was like, oh come on man.
And that took another 20 minutes
to get to use all freaked out.
I was like, you couldn't tell somebody
like you couldn't script this happening.
The hidden crying dog shit,
smoke detector,
fire department back.
I mean it was the worst night.
And then two nights later the dog got
diarrhea again and I was up all night with
that mother fuck dog.
So I took bitsy to the vet again cause we,
we thought it was because
she was eating stuff.
It turns out she has
inflammatory bowel disorder,
disease, whatever it is for different than
traditional IBS. Ibs is psychological.
They say it's stress related,
but she doesn't have diarrhea when she
gets groomed or anything unrelated to to
that. So get something in
Brussels. They're great dogs.
But I think genetically she's got some
stuff that dog's butt hole has been the
only problem with his dog is to togs
asshole. Let's um, yeah. So anyways,
we put her down yesterday.
Our guest is here, she's here,
she's going to be on a new diet.
And I'm giving her hemp oil twice
a day and hopefully in a new food,
a softer food that's going to help
her. So, uh, our guest is here though.
Let's take a quick break and grab him.
All right.
We're back and we have with us
our guests preferred pronouns.
He him post transition.
One of my favorite comedians
in the world. Also. Uh,
one of the stars of,
we've mentioned many times.
I need you to kill the comedy
documentary directed by j Elvis Weinstein
that's available on Amazon prime.
Uh, multiple standup albums, male,
multiple television appearances,
a new special that was just shot that
will be coming to you somewhere soon.
You'll announce when you
have all the information.
It is the great Chad Daniels.
Hi everyone.
[inaudible]
Chad,
Danny
[inaudible].
There you go. You're so funny.
You're the best. Thank you guys.
And you're one of those people that more
people need to know about it's time.
It's time. I love when he used to talk
about your wife drinking red wine.
Oh Shit. What was the red wine? Her teeth.
It'd be all purple and gross.
So many great jokes.
He's one of the great joke writers,
so that's nice.
It's funny because people will
come up and they'll be like, hey,
can you do this bit tonight?
I'd like to see me before a show.
I can't because I'm divorced
and don't talk about her.
It's just not fair. Do you have a lot of
divorce material? I don't have any. Any.
Uh Huh. Do you do that purposefully?
Because well, it's just like her.
It's her life, you know? So if
it's not 100% my story to tell,
then I don't tell it. What's it
do you mean because you have kids,
do you still interact? Right? Absolutely.
Yeah. She was eight blocks away.
We live in the same town
style. Wow. Split custody.
So we have to talk about a kid's
schedules and cod. I feel like,
not that it's definitely not
the biggest part of divorce,
but isn't one of the things that
when you remove the emotional stuff,
you know,
aside the logistics of scheduling,
is that one of the things you're like,
God damn it that like you didn't plan
on when you divorced, you're like,
I gotta I gotta set up Tuesday.
Yeah, Tuesday worked out.
You know what I mean?
It is tough that the hardest part was
watching my daughter come over with like
her laundry basket and
it's like, I go, well,
why don't you put those in the dresser so
it's not such a pain for you? She goes,
well, I mean I have to bring it back
and forth. And I was like, Oh God,
I fucking hardest breaking.
You know what?
I will buy one of each for one here and
one there and then you don't have to
bring shit back and forth.
Now that's the sad part is the worst.
But let's talk about the good part.
Say
that new post doc, I wish
what? Like a divorce too late.
Everybody's like, oh, you're
divorced. Sorry. And then
just absolutely. Really true.
You're not getting it in second wife
Tom and I keep talking about what his
second wife,
we're hoping that I get like a Dalmatian,
you know like the girl,
you're so funny and her and her brain
growth outgrows her skull and she goes
crazy. I know. That's
what happens to Dalmatian.
They're adorable. This puppy is
amazing. Yeah. When they're three,
their brain outgrows their skull and I
conscious,
yeah,
I want to get that girl who's just
like, hey, you have guns show.
She's like, I got a hand bat live
at time. And I'm like, that's great.
And then I'm like, anyways. And she's
like, ah, a blowjob time. I'm like, yeah.
And then just, and then
she's like, I'll go to,
I'll go the other room so he could sleep.
Watch your football demands on you.
Ever,
ever.
Absolutely. Takes care of everything for
you. Yeah. I could be like fucking go.
I have just work for Alaska going on
a football game trip with my friends.
She's like, I have a a labia. Where do
you find, is there a second workshop?
I think they're just out there.
They're there on the road. Their road.
Biebs Phoenix, let's be, yeah,
that road beams out there waiting for you.
Houston there and FEMA and hot places.
There's Tampa Tampa's our headquarters.
Well, I picked northern Minnesota
where everybody gets the pretty girl
from dairy queen gets married at 17 and
fucking stays married forever. That's
right. It's a problem. Seriously.
You need to relocate where the hot
sluts live. Yeah. Listen, four years,
four years and it'll be here.
So cow. Yeah, I think so.
This weather is unbelievable.
My daughter's a freshman and I might
homeschooler from here sophomore through
senior year. So Nice. Maybe.
Um, yeah, I know. So nice here.
It really is. I always say whether it's
underrated when people are like, oh yeah,
the weather is like, no, no, no.
Whether his life dictates everything.
When you can go outside.
I mean,
it's going to be gray for
nine months where I'm at. I
did my fucking living room,
sky blue,
which is not recommended by anyone.
Only to have blue in my life. Had
a winter. Yeah. Yeah, Bro. Listen,
we got sunshine Avocados.
You've had one of those before,
not one that's ready to eat. What
if, what if Chad's whole cynical,
shitty take on everything is just tied
to living in first fault and that he
moves down here and he'll be like,
I have a banana every morning,
and then his act has turned into like
this. You guys ever rent a Prius?
Everyone's like, what happened
to you? He's like, I don't
know. I feel great. Yeah,
that's his whole acronym.
So happy.
I want it to happen.
So we've got to keep you from getting
second wife Puss in another town so that
you actually come to southern
California so we can be around you.
I'm telling you, I don't,
it just isn't. It's not a,
people see me on stage and I'm like,
he's grumpy and he has a grown man child,
so we don't need to talk to
him after this. Let's go try
this. So hard to believe.
I really do. It's real. Now you got
to put out the don't.
You got to lace it into the material.
Never ever going to do that. Have you ever
seen a fucking divorced comic onstage?
Yeah. Will I learn this new, uh,
you know, bud fucking and it's
office. You sit there and you're
like, are you trolling right now?
I've seen that it's also seen the not
well hidden attempt to get laid with like,
and that's why I don't ever, I
never get to any sex, you know?
And then they pull it
out there.
Ladies, you guys are the superior sex, am
I right? And then the pandering to how,
how great women are. Yeah. The fake
feminist. That's my favorite move.
I can't believe that they told you guys
I'm staying at the courtyard Marriott.
I'm in room six oh nine.
And they just open with believe
all women. You're like, how come
I can't chat that exactly.
I want to be in my second marriage.
I want to be the frivolous older
housewife woman who has not a care in the
world. Like you've seen her on
reality shows where she's like,
like everything's funny and I just,
I just need to buy a grill
for $5,000 whole life is like,
I got to get Amanda here. You're
constantly remodeling. Yeah.
Every year you're like, ah, this
house, it just doesn't feel right.
This kitchen, it's not like what
I'm cooking. Exactly. Yeah. Yeah.
And then they're like,
that's what I want you to know that
there's such thing as a chef's kitchen.
And then you're like, what? And
then your husband just like,
just build what you want.
That's what I'll have you like.
Do you know there's such
thing as a chef and fucking
fucking cooking lessons bay, but I'm
drunk all the time. I'm always brunching.
You're just like wine buzzed all day.
And the husband worked so hard
just to keep me in the world.
You know that I don't see him.
We don't even have a relationship's fine.
You spend recklessly,
epically, recklessly.
So I wanted to be an epic once every
few months. He was like, I mean,
600 grand on the AMX cheese, but don't
I look good sweetie? Pretty true.
And it's cheaper to keep her
head and he puts you behind each.
Just say I'm a be home.
Keep me then to divorce me. That's why
he keeps me. Yeah, it's true. Yeah.
It has a fair isn't it's fine cause I'm
not giving them a second wife works.
That's so great. No, that's how it works.
You guys are really setting this up.
Not a great life.
You know when you make to California,
you're going to find your second.
He's going to get pissy.
Where's it going? Or if I'm not
sperm vine sued. Everybody listening.
Go see Chad Daniels Irvine. This drops
your listing. Yeah. You have time.
If you're listening right
now as it comes out tomorrow,
Wednesday night he's going to be in
Irvine and the Irvine Improv looking for
love or different. Really?
He's not looking for one.
Making this seem so sad. No.
Can someone say hi to Chad Tomas Hog?
He likes his balls tugged right hard.
Do you like pulled hard?
We just read an email about pulling hard.
I have really sensitive nuts.
So yeah, so you're like no
thanks. It's like just keep it up.
Just keep it above the
sac. Yeah. Above this.
So you don't want like, you don't want
to like that. They're just real sense.
I don't know. Like there are
always bruised or something.
I don't know what's going on
and I got to have a sec to me.
And zero problems didn't hurt no pain.
They uh,
talked to Tom about this cause I, I
need this to happen. You had paint. Oh,
you haven't gotten one? No.
Yeah, I can't have another kid.
Yeah, it's something in a,
in a jar and then freeze it.
If you want to have another with your
second wife are having more children.
Are you sure baby man,
I wanted a
sperm set.
Call
it a dinosaur. It sounded
kind of like it, right?
Walk us through the process.
Yeah, we went in and the guy, uh,
he has an APP. He's like a accent. He's
a, by the way, is this in Ferguson?
Do you have a setup appointment
before this to like, yeah.
So you have to go in and I'm asking you,
you have to go in and get the consult.
And during the consult though, he
said, uh, because of a vasectomy,
you can speed up cancer in your
crotch area. Why everywhere prostate?
I don't know. Well, here's the thing.
Don't tell people that this is
true because I don't know if he,
maybe he was just fucking with me. Maybe
in a small town, maybe he was just like,
oh, funny man. Huh. Right. But
anyways, yeah. So he gave me the,
you want cancer, prostate, prostate exam,
and then I went in and it's like people
I went to high school with or the nurses.
Oh Christ.
So you're sitting there
with a shaved everything.
Right. It's freezing in the
room. Not an excuse. Right.
Uh, but it's just weird. Yeah,
of course. Falls. Remember when,
remember when we had creative writing
together and they're like moving your dick
to the other leg and you're like,
cool, this is so comfortable, man.
I've never seen my dick as small as
I've seen it in a doctor's office.
You know? It is funny. It's like
I've looked down and been like,
you've gotta be kidding me. Then
this is just like for a physical, I,
I'll feel like I got to fluff
this a little bit just for
like my own self esteem.
You really think he's looking at you and
I don't think so. I think I'm just like,
what the fuck? I'm better
than this, you know?
Do you think about like nakedness and Ah,
I think I'm just more like just smacking
around. Yeah, just smack around.
Just to give it like,
just some dignity. I mean,
I've seen it literally a new level of
small in a doctor's office when you have
to Wipe when you pee.
Do we have a concave Dick
Right now? What's going on?
I mean like retreats inside.
I've never seen it. I think it's because
of the medical atmosphere and you know,
you're a little, you know, somebody
poking and prodding. Yeah. You're nervous.
It's cold. It's always fucking cold.
Yeah. I got embarrassed when my doctor,
I was like nine months pregnant.
My doctor was examining me and I farted
right in his hands and I was like,
I just, I farted on you. He's like,
it's okay. I remember that. No,
I was there the the time after and he's
like, farts happen. Everybody farts.
But he's still talking about it somehow.
Yeah. Two months later, two months,
two months, 11 months pregnant.
That's, I'm not going to match.
So weight on the, so the console is, he
gives you, he's like, you're gonna die.
And then he, he gives you a further exam
and he was like, okay, sum up the deal.
Really Healy, I have to
tell you, have you ever,
he lubed up the whole
glove and I actually said,
my insurance is not going to pay for
all that because there was a doll up.
You know what a dollop is? That requires a
spoon. Yeah. And it was, I was just like,
what in the fuck. So he goes,
elbows on the desk. It wasn't,
I still don't think this is what should
have happened because it was so weird.
Elbows on the desk and he just goes
in now why is the thumb, I don't know.
Well, maybe it was, I don't know. I guess
I wasn't looking, but I assumed phone.
That's what I would've done. Wow.
So he fingers, you're be home. Yup.
And then when you come so
hard all over and he goes,
that's not cancer.
That's just a great time.
I had to go like,
did it come out and do this morning?
Did he take his nails and then gently
prod right in between my shoulder blades.
He bunched up my shirt and
twisted it and I was like, Ooh,
I like this a lot. So console, he's
like, you're good to go. Your asshole,
your balls, everything's good.
Yup. And then you come back.
He said it like that cause that your
asshole, you're bald, everything's good.
Come back. How long later? Next week?
Maybe two weeks. Something like that.
And so what's the day like when you
go, is there a preppy, he's like,
don't eat before. Like how does
it go? You can do whatever.
You just have to shave
everything. Everything. Yep.
Nope, but taint twigging Mary's, I
like to get maybe halfway down. Yeah,
I got long taint hair
when I'm in the shower.
Sometimes I'll go down and I'll
look at it. I'll just see like,
I mean everyone does
when you walk, it's like when you wash a
dog though, the hair always looks longer.
That's true. That's true. It's
like a dog's beard. Hang. Yeah.
From my tank always looks longer cause
it's like altogether and then pointing
down the water's got to go some gravity.
Let's blame it on gravity.
So you go, you go in, you're all shaved
and then he's just like, how does it,
how does it, how does it
start? Like what was he like?
Okay,
it looks like the opening scene of up,
there's two ladies in there and then uh,
they strapped
you down. No, I'm just kidding.
But they just, you know,
they tell you don't move,
don't touch anything and
then you can smell it.
You can smell the Qataris
cauterizing catheterization.
Clearly they do Nami that they shoot
you in the, in the vast with the local
cool. But the vast, the
vast offerings. So, okay.
You feel it. You feel different. Zach,
Zach Efron and injection.
Yeah.
You feel that and then after that
you don't feel anything. Right.
But you do smell. Yeah, you
can smell when there long.
Does that help procedure take,
I don't know, 20 minutes maybe.
No soreness afterwards.
Why you had to sit on a bag of peas and
I didn't lift anything for the weekend.
But otherwise that's, that's it. And then
how many jackets do you have to Jack?
Before,
I think I had to bring in three samples
to make sure there's no swimmers.
The Crystal meth before you Jack,
take crystal meth. And whenever I
see that sounds really easy town.
That doesn't sound too bad
for me.
It was, I mean, your kids are little.
So if you ha if you start over,
no, that's not, I mean, I have a 19 year
old, the 14 year old, that'd be nice.
So you throw a fucking baby into that
negative. And where's the bridge? Yeah,
for me, not that I'm not a monster. Right,
right. But you would definitely be like,
there goes my life. Well, I mean, imagine,
imagine four years left on your prison
sentence and then you shoot somebody in
the yard and they're like, you're
here forever now. I mean, that's,
that's how I think about it. I mean,
if, what if you got someone? Yeah.
So now you can't get someone pregnant.
I sure can't. Yeah. And you got,
you tested that a few times
and I've called in and I go,
so do I need to test us like every
six months and a they go, you don't,
and I'll just bring it in anyways.
I'm like, can we make sure we really,
absolutely nuts. And Robbie left and
right. It sounds like it's not road beef.
It's just me needing an excuse to
jerk off and feeling whole about it.
Oh, I see. Wow. So was Tom. I'm,
are we doing this or what? Doing
what? Oh, you're getting snips.
I'll get snipped please. Uh,
let's do a live remote from there. How
about December? Since I'm a home from
scratch. Seriously. I would love that.
I've been on birth control since I
was 15 and I can't do it anymore.
But you know, they'll make you do mouth
checks. That's what the doctrine is.
Taste test. You have to go like, yeah,
there's nothing in there that can get
me pregnant. You have to do it like, oh,
okay.
Can I just tell you,
you just blew my mind because I burped
and kept it in my throat and then you
burped in. The noise came through
and I was like, did I just fucking
Melton
respectful exact same time.
I kept it in my throat. God. Oh,
that was nuts. That is got it.
Crazy
synergy. Synergy. Oh wait, two
people bourbon fart at the same time.
It's really magical stuff.
You guys are really good friends.
We're sinked up our cycle. Do you
have any weird porns that you're into?
Like are you into watch and weird stuff?
I don't and it's gotten to the point,
no weird kinks.
It's almost the opposite of that where,
you know,
something will be on and then I'll just
have to stop and be like, wait a second.
That's his real mom. Not like a step. I
can't watch this shit. That's disgusting.
I was watching two Russians, one, or
excuse me, two Germans one time and uh,
I was all ready to go.
Everything locked and loaded and uh,
and one of the ladies looked at the
other one and goes, sucks these tits,
you bitch. And I couldn't stop laughing
and I just was like, well, this is done.
Yeah, I wish we had that audio for
this show. It's you bitches. Great.
I laughed. So goddamn on.
Yeah, there's weird stuff
that's like bald porn.
But we had a,
we played, uh, we had Josh potter
come in. He brought in weird,
like some of the weirdest
stuff he could find.
And then we've put a call out there
for other weird things, you know,
just beyond the normal,
the vanilla stuff.
And we got this email says, hey,
I just watched episode four,
69 of when Josh Potter was on and showed
me the video of a nameless hero doing
God's work and servicing the genitals
of prep, of crippled, undesirables,
the topic of disabled porn and more
specifically porn with people who are
missing limbs came up. And as a
20 year old man missing both legs,
let me tell you, the people who
fetishize missing limbs are very real.
Someone with an amputee fetish
is revert to as a divo tea.
And there are different sides of it.
Some people just want to
have sex with an amputee.
Some people get sexual pleasure from
the desire to become an amputee.
There are certain instances where people
have actually mutilated themselves to
become an amputee so they can pop a
bone bone and then squirt till sundown.
It is very common for amputees to have
people randomly messaged them on Facebook
and other social media and ask to see
pictures of their stump or ask me if they
ever use their stump during sex.
There are mixed feelings in the amputee
community about divo teas because some
people think it's gross. Some
people think it's nice. Personally,
I think that knowing someone may want to,
Russell my jimmies due to me missing
limbs is awesome. Many people,
many people missing limbs
are very self conscious feel.
They may never find someone who
will want to skeet there, mate.
Knowing the Divo t his exists can,
uh,
it gives myself and other crippled hope
too that we can get our dicks lik to
thank you for bringing up yet another
important topic and for truly being the
voice of the people and America's
podcast piss on me. Beat me.
And a face of Fart, Nathan, a pacifier.
And these emails are so beautifully
written. Yeah, that's fantastic. Um,
so I didn't know that there was
that whole segment of society.
How do you get there?
Do you lose your virginity to somebody
with thick legs and you're like,
I need more access to actually,
how do we do that?
I'm always fascinating to though that
whatever your condition, whatever it is,
there is somebody that's very turned
on by that you can be 600 pounds.
You could be missing a limb, you can be
unable to walk. And someone out there,
I was like, God, I fucking love that shit.
Such a turn on. I mean they really do.
There's really something that
turns everybody on. I Dunno.
Not In Minneapolis. Fergus falls, the
Fergus falls. No, maybe not. Well again,
I told you they're all married and
they've been non married. Yeah,
we got to find you.
The hot pot weather slots,
the hot weather sluts. They're
out there, man. Arizona.
You're right. I'm real slots. Are
Somebody also message that, um,
whoever did that Photoshop gang member
of the guys transitioning to women,
they said that they did me dirty.
You have. And they told me, Tom,
you have serious potential
as a super hot chick.
You look like a Russian porn star.
How God should have made Jesus.
I am rock hard and came to
four strokes on these. Uh,
love you both and your
podcast is hilarious. Shaun.
Shaun said this is a better
representation of me as huh? Uh Huh.
That's actually, that's
you as a, as a woman. Yeah.
Well that's somebody who
I think put maybe my,
maybe my eyes in they're little
and then half did the mouth.
Well, here's the problem with your
transition that I foresee. First of all.
Oh, that's better. That's
your hairline. We're going to have
to do some restaurant chain. Yeah.
Like major surgery there to bring
it down a little bit more. Uh,
electrolysis. You've got so much facial
hair, a lot of hormones and your size.
You're so big.
We're going to have to thin
you out three to pass. Wow.
I mean, what are you doing
mentally? She just kicked the shit.
I know. I mean, as a woman,
I think it's a compliment that
it would be really complex.
Like she's been wanting to say all that
shit for a long time and this was just a
way to sneak it in. I think
you're, I'm just saying as a woman,
as a woman, not pass. Do you think you'd
ever do anything for your hairline?
Um, no. Good for you. No.
No. I've got to let it ride.
I think you look great too. I'm
just doing the, uh, the buzzing.
That's it. Trim it down.
Absolutely. Yeah. That's it. Yeah.
You've got a full head of hair, right?
I do. Lucky guy. Yeah. Well thank you.
It's very, it's nice. Yup. Got that going
for me. I can the full head of hair.
Oh my God. You show do fucking,
when we were in Asia together,
every chick walked up to him
and I was like, you're hot
shot. Like serious hair. Yeah,
they did. They were super anything.
My sunken in eyeballs because I hadn't
slept in two weeks. It's like, hey,
hey ladies. Yeah. Every
single one of them.
Ridiculous.
He ever dated Asian persuasion?
I have not.
Okay.
Maybe single Chad. Well, no, I mean,
not for any reason. It's just again,
because you're racist.
Northern Minnesota,
so it's like when we did a white girl or
a wider girl. Yeah, that's true, right?
Yeah.
It's super white. Is there any
diversity? Northern Minnesota.
Very little.
Yeah.
That's another thing is going to happen
when you move to that hot pissy climate,
you're going to get different,
different looks. Man.
That's going to be exciting for you.
Different look. Definitely Indian girl,
Asian girls, fucking black Latina.
It's all gonna come to you.
You're gonna be knocking
the chicks off your Dick.
Yeah. I mean there's no doubt
about it. Can I ask you a question?
Yeah. How long does it take you to Fart
in front of somebody after you meet them?
I'm like, do you fart in front of
girls? You fart in front of friends.
Shabby farted in front of Tom.
You guys have been friends for years.
I, I mean, I don't know if I have to.
I do. Do you know where I met Chad?
I met him on the flight at the airport
right before the flight to Hong Kong,
so we met there. That's when we met. We,
we'd heard about each other and talk.
I think we've tweeted each other
or message each other before.
And I remember one of the first things I
did on that flight was I went to take a
shit and that was in there probably 10
feet and I just met Chad and as I walk
out of it, you know there's
always a little bit of like,
I wonder if anyone noticed.
I was in the bathroom for like 10 minutes.
So I was on the flight. I just shut the
door head down. I look up and Chaz like
it was 16 minutes and he looked at me.
Yeah.
What were you doing? Yeah, he was really
letting me know that he knew that I took,
it doesn't count for the Mile High Club.
So wait,
you're asking me about farting though?
Well, because my husband Tom has this
neat habit of just farting in front of
everybody.
Sure.
And he just told me yesterday we
were eating dinner and he goes, I,
I was working out with my trainer and
I just farted in front of him on the
treadmill and the other guys really mad
and the gym. And I was like,
well, of course they're mad dummy.
Nobody wants to smell your farts.
What happened was I'm running, no,
that's what happened. And
I go like, alternate story.
And then my trainers like, you
know, probably 10 feet away,
he's sitting on one of those boxes,
you know, those box jump things.
And he was like, he goes,
was that the, was it,
was that the treadmill? He
was, he was genuinely confused.
Like, what was it? I go,
yeah, it was a treadmill. And I go,
no, I farted. And he was like, okay.
And then I go, oof man, that smells bad.
Smells were really bad. And he's
like, great. And it's a small,
it's like a small chin.
And then like 10 seconds
later I smelled this fresh,
like unbelievably fresh scent. I'm like,
what the fuck is that? He's like, Oh,
I just sprayed down this
whole gym with this natural,
and then I realized that that whole time,
10 feet behind,
he was another guy just sitting down on
like another piece of equipment and I go,
oh, I didn't know you were back there.
He was like, yeah, yeah, it was,
you know when people really want you
to put shit particles into the air when
they're breathing their hardest,
right?
Maximum heart rate and you
just shit right in there.
And I feel like it's dangerous to
hold it in at the gym for some reason.
I always let it rip at the gym.
I feel like when you're like exerting
yourself and they're trying to punish
yourself and you're like,
oh, this is uncomfortable,
I'm not going to hold it in.
I've always thought to myself,
you ever want to meet the prettiest girl
in the world going out to a hotel gym
and Fart? Because she'll be there in
two minutes. He will, right? Yeah.
And you'll have it to yourself for 45
minutes at minute 47 now all of a sudden
you're like, oh, hey, no. Did you see that
other guy walking out? Wow. What a jerk.
Right?
He said he was going to
say, cause it's become a pattern for Tom
now where he's just been kind of farting
indiscriminately.
Like we had Doug Mallard in here and he
brought his fiance over within minutes
of meeting her,
he farted in front of her at our dinner
and I'm surprised you haven't fired it
in front of our nanny.
And then she came right in the
other night and smelled that.
I think once you get
through the first couple,
[inaudible] happens.
Sometimes what I do is fart and I go,
oh my gosh,
I'm so embarrassed. We try to justify
it. You guys, this is amazing.
I haven't floated in, here's the
doctor said I'd never fart again.
It's what an accomplishment.
This is actually a celebration right now.
I can't believe you guys were
here to witness this. Exciting.
So I'm guessing you don't do
this in front of people. I don't.
I don't know what it is.
I think a single guy
now that's what it is.
He's looking for that new
road beef and he knows that.
You can't find your way there,
but that now if you go
out on a date a few times,
let's say if you get comfortable,
how long would it take you to fart in
front of a lady or do you know that
normally at first happens on
accident, right? Is it a few
months in? Probably. Yeah.
Probably like something like a,
you have a good jumper cables where
they come in and just both sides of your
ribs. Yeah. That happened once.
She thought it was going to be so
funny and I just all over. Yeah.
And that that was acting. Then I'm like,
well thank you for, we broke the barrier.
Yeah. Thanks for doing that. Yeah.
Somebody emailed in about this. Uh, Hey
Tom McCarthy. I'm a woman in her thirties.
I have more gas than anyone I know.
Dating is hard for me because
I get crippling stomachache
and basically have to
run home just to Fart.
How early is too early to start farting
in front of a significant other? Uh,
I currently just met a guy.
He's very fun but very polite.
He doesn't seem like the type of person
I could in front of Fart in front of
ever. Oh, should I end it now?
Should I just give up on dating?
I'm not completely haggard.
I'm a pretty normal looking girl.
Just within an excessive amount of gas.
Sincerely Gassy,
Kaitlin. I feel okay. Let's start
from the, the science of it.
Do you know why you're so gassy?
Have you gone to the doctor?
Maybe it's your diet. What are you doing?
Is there any way to reduce your gas?
Change what you're eating and it should,
it should affect it.
Maybe like Betsy puts some hemp oil,
like our dog on your food.
See if that is your stomach. Yeah. Why?
Why do you have to run all the way home?
Can't you just like leave the room?
Yeah.
It's probably on how smelling
you'd be like, I just, uh,
I drank so much water before I got
here today and just keep going to the
bathroom to pee or be like, I'm a good
person and I'm leaving a room to fart.
Right. Does it this way? You don't
have to buy what we're finding. We're,
we're missing the, the, the, the, the,
the thing that she should be
pursuing. What the guy that
loves farts. That's your,
and I gotta say, yeah, there's a lot
of them out there. It's surprising.
We discovered that a while ago and we
got a whole bunch of messages from guys
who are like, the whole idea of a pretty
girl making a stinky smell turns me off.
They love it. Now if you can handle
the smell of your own farts. Yeah.
I'm sure there are guys that would
love to suck it into their mouth,
come up and then blow
it back in your face.
There are guys out there that it would
have been nothing more than Kaitlin
farting around. Maybe she doesn't
want like a fetish person. Yeah. No,
but it's somebody who, who likes her
and like, and also like that. Yeah.
Is a Fraser fight,
Caitlin.
There's also gas x and phase. I'm, if
you've tried taking those, you may want,
right. She's asking me, well,
I've got so far it's been, no,
she's asking you about
what to do about this dude.
I would say get your diet checked out.
Take the phase,
I'm the Bino and hang
out with him for awhile.
Or maybe just say, hey man, go off. You'll
be as nice. A lot of interesting. Yes.
But up, Eh, we cheese. Uh, your main
characteristic, your page
out, your main characteristic.
Well,
my main characteristic of my
specialty is a face farting.
Yeah. Yeah. I'm playing this like
your power is the best part. Uh,
let's see. I Dunno. I Dunno.
I don't know.
Oh, that's it. Okay.
Oh, that's it. Oh yeah.
I don't know which episode that's in.
Okay. All right. Ready? All right.
Well this is happening out on the street.
There's a truck driving. Yeah. Yeah.
It's out on the street. No,
they're in front of like a
dairy queen. It's terrible.
Yeah. It's really stupid. Yeah.
Wow. There you go. You know what?
I just reminded me of Tommy
talking about 40 at the gym.
Tom and I used to live in silver lake,
which is a predominantly gay area.
We used to work out at this gym that
was known for having bears workout.
They're like big dudes.
And they remember that one bear
that would always build his mosque.
How can I forget?
And he would like,
he would use a treadmill that
was placed right? Like the,
there was a fan right in front of him.
There's always that fucking asshole.
And then his bear juice
is just being spread.
I'm trying to do a podcast and
rafting and the smell of this guy,
his balls just throughout the
whole jam or that guy did it work?
Did they attract other cub?
Yeah, of course. At work.
Dude smelled horrendous and
was the biggest guy in the gym.
Like a big Samoan, you
know, like six, three,
three 30 had fucking Pearce knows
crazy tattoos and just stunk that.
He would just proudly walk around like,
and that works a smell.
I mean it must've worked.
It must have worked.
I don't know what these base by face,
right?
That's a guy who pretends to understand
what phase farting mates. Yeah.
So he's like, what these
these, it's Italian guy. And
she's like, let me show you.
He's like, okay. Soon as she does,
he's like, thank you. That was amazing.
He's special.
That's what Katelyn needs. Yeah.
Just a face farting guy. A pig. Yeah.
A real pig. I think you'll find out
that, uh, you know, if the guys into you,
you can fart whenever.
It doesn't matter.
I've had girls around me
all the time and it doesn't,
we haven't finished the truth of it.
Let's have Chad way. Yeah, sure, sure.
So I'm doing the psychopath test.
Oh, great. Psychology test here.
And Christina is doing it too.
Um,
and I need to answer a few more
questions on the air we all take down,
aren't here. I'll give you a
paper pen if you want. Sure.
You can take down some answers.
So here's the,
here is the question number six. Uh,
by the way, that the way that you, uh,
the number score, this is, um,
a five is a very good match to the,
to the statement.
Okay.
A four is a good three is moderate
to slight and one nothing.
So think of it as one means.
I actually do not agree with the statement
for yourself or is that how you're
doing it, right? Yeah. Okay. So the
next question, do you think I am like,
I feel like if four's good, I got
the rest of them all the way down.
Just like to give explicit
instructions. Sorry. Um,
I find that I am able to pursue
one goal for a long time. Okay.
Let's see here. I'm
answering that. Okay. Uh,
next question. My main purpose in life
is to get as many goodies as I can.
Get a definition on goodies. Yeah,
exactly. It's road beef. Yeah.
Hmm.
Okay.
Um,
next one is I don't play on
anything very far in advance.
Okay.
Oh, next one's interesting. Making a
lot of money is my most important goal.
It's a fine.
Mm.
And let's see, we don't want to bore
people with just reading these questions.
So what, we're going to share our
answers. I know we are very shortly,
I quickly lose interest in tasks I start.
Hmm.
And I let others worry
about higher values.
My main concern is with
the bottom line cheese.
It's a yes for Tom.
Not at all.
No. All right. All right, well that's a
guy that's number six through 11. Yeah.
So let's go ahead and share our answers.
Okay.
I find that I'm able to pursue
one goal for a long time.
This is strong match for me.
I five what'd you get? Oh,
were the two a a slight, slight
match for you. Okay, go ahead.
Um, my main purpose in life is
to get as many goodies as I can.
I'm a too. And what were the
three? I went with a three. Wow.
These are fucking psychos. Okay. That's
of moderate match shark. Go ahead.
I don't plan anything very far in advance.
I got a four just because we have two
children who are prone to sickness.
Standup careers.
Yeah.
I went with a three because
in my professional life I
have to plan things a year
in advance. And in my personal
life, I don't know what's
happening tomorrow. Trail.
And what was the one you
don't, you don't plan it all.
Oh, I misinterpreted that. Hold
on. Sorry. Read the question again.
The statement is I don't plan anything
very far in advance and I feel like I do
plan things very far in advance. So that's
a one meaning you disagree with that?
I disagree with the statement
that I don't plan things. We do.
You do plenty of things, right, so I
think I interpreted correct. Listen,
I'm just going to admit I put three
down for all of these cause I didn't
understand any of them. Okay. How
about this one? This is very revealing.
Making a lot of money is my most
important goal for hello to Jesus.
I put a four as well,
but you have to understand,
I live in a place where
if comedy doesn't pan out,
that's what I tell people when
they're not laughing. I go,
do you think this fucking matters?
I could mow lawns and make my mortgage.
I live in the middle of nowhere.
That's very interesting. Yeah.
I like,
but I like having all og
money or money's great,
but I'm just saying like where I live,
I don't need a lot of it. That's trail.
I quickly lose interest in tests.
I start. Where do you go for that?
I'd strongly disagree. That's a one.
That's where I went. Five. Did you really?
Oh absolutely.
I have fucking lumber for stuff that I
was going to build three years ago in my
garage. Still. I think I
should be more, I think I,
now that I hear this and like
talk about it, I put a one,
but I think it's fair to give
myself a couple points higher.
You lose interest in,
I mean, I'm a thing in,
I don't think it's a complete
five and I don't think it's a one.
I think I probably should be at two
or three. I agree with that, you know,
because there's things that I'm very
much able to pursue as a task and,
and then there are some things that I
like hearing him say. I'm like, yeah,
I've done that where I've bought
the thing to do the thing.
And then I'm just like,
man,
I haven't listened to a full sentence
this entire time, so I'm for sure. Okay.
Okay. Um, all right, so here we go.
And then I let others
worry about higher values.
My main concern is with the bottom line,
if that isn't not to bait
the craziest of the crazy.
And people who hear that and
they're like, definitely. Um, I,
I don't agree with that at all.
I was a two
de got to leave a little space.
Little space is good.
All right. Clearly Chad
is the sociopath. No, no,
I'd say there's no doubt
about it. I'm very calm. Yeah.
Well, you know, we learned about
our heart, right? That's true.
So I was watching this a crime
documentary thing on Netflix and uh,
they said that one,
it's not confirmed,
but it's like proposed idea that's
an indicator for sociopath is,
uh, is that many of them have
a low resting heart rate.
And the theory is that they need
excitement to just feel alive,
feel normal. Yeah. To get,
to get to normal so that they do
things that are high risk and you know,
crazy things basically to just elevate
that heart rate. That's always,
I mean,
you remember when I
slid down the wet hill and Hong
Kong to traffic? Yeah. Uh, that,
that is right.
By the way,
a,
that is a not completely vivid
description of what he did was terrifying.
I mean, on, on it then or purpose.
So on purpose on a hill in the rain,
Steep Hill and there they have a uh,
in the city and not like they have an
escalator. That's how steep the hill is.
Yes. So everyone's on this escalator cause
there's a top over it and it's raining
fuck.
And with all the soot in the air,
it comes down with the rain and
made it very greasy for yeah.
So that the hillside is like, it's
basically the picture wet brick, you know,
it's like God v and he gets a
trashcan lid off jumps monster going.
Yeah. And slides down
like, like headfirst.
Like it's like an angel.
Oh my God.
We just like see him going and then we
just see cars rounding a turn coming
around.
He's down
talking to a taxi, trying to negotiate
to get back across the bay to our hotel.
He pulls his head out, the window
looks at me and goes, what the fuck?
And then back in negotiating it was
wow, it was really scary. Nightmarish.
But my resting heart rate's nine,
so I need to do stuff like that.
Say both of you are psychos. Like, I
have a really low resting heart rate too.
I had it where like they were
like one guy, the Nice Guy,
the nice tech at the,
at Cedars when they were
examining my heart was like, man,
it's really low. He's like, uh,
do you work out? Yeah. And I go,
yeah. And then like the nurse
came in who was no nonsense.
She was like, it looks at the thing. She
was like, wow, it's really low. He goes,
the guy goes, he works out though. And
she looks at me. She's like, no, no, no,
not like that.
He doesn't,
this is something upstairs
mouse. Yeah. Um, anyways,
yeah. So maybe that's,
is that the root of it, you
know? Well, that could be,
I want to see a total fucking pig. Yeah.
At the airport, somebody sent this in.
Was this from the actual listener says,
I'm currently waiting for my flight
home and witnessed something absolutely
disgusting in a,
in the middle of a crowded terminal.
This is low and loose behavior and has
absolutely floored me in a terminal.
No,
no,
no. This guy. Oh my God,
this is, I'm going to vomit. She
goes on to say, she says this guy,
I took his shoes and socks off,
started picking at the skin between his
toes and peeling his blisters right here
in the terminal.
I mean that is savagery.
That is absolute insanity to witness.
So inappropriate.
I've seen people clip their nails.
Yes. In public on airplanes.
It's so gross.
My daughter was really bothering
me one week and so I picked up,
I took the whole skin off of a blister
and let it dry and then I put it on her
pillow.
She hoes fucking murdered me in my sleep.
But you know what? Don't be an asshole all
week. Yeah, that's true. She was really,
yeah. Yeah. It's just, you know, she come
and tell you when she discovered it. Yeah.
She, I mean she screamed. She
didn't come tell me. Oh, she just,
she sat above her bed yard, gas,
gas to just freaking out when
you were like, yeah, go to bed.
Just give her one of those resting
heart rate. Yeah. Very calm.
Very calm.
Do you think that grooming in any
enclosed space with other humans that you
don't, you're not related to is just
disgusting. It's completely unacceptable.
I vomit.
Even just having some girl brush her
fucking horsey hair on the airplane.
It's crazy.
Why are you brushing your hair and all
your dirty Dandre flakes are everywhere
in the, in the year. Yeah. You know,
and your dirty fucking hair. Yeah.
The thing is everyone knows what the,
I mean, if you're clipping your nails,
you're so fucking by God to do
that in a plane or a terminal.
So I've seen people,
well, just fun clip, clip light. That
actually reminded me of that brush thing.
My daughter has pulled all the hair
out of her bra and then packed it in my
suitcase. That's pretty great. That's
pretty great. It's a smart girl.
It was a fucking cause. You pull out
your stuff, you're like, oh my God.
It's like, it's my version of a love
note, Dan. I love you. Come back soon.
Oh my God. That's fine. Um, let's
see if this motivates Chad too.
Maybe. I don't know. Open his mind.
Open his heart and change the
way he sees things. You know,
I'm sitting here in the desert. It was
just looking at this beautiful vastness,
um,
and thinking of those times of how I've
compromised myself because I was so
afraid to be alone and this
desert reminded me of lonely
path I've had to travel
within and how I've had to put everything
that I love and everything I've built
on the line to simply be happy and how
it can be the most terrifying thing to
do.
You can feel absolutely lonely.
This is why people cheat right here.
This kind of shit. Yeah, right.
Hey, check out this video. I did all
right. Yeah. You're like, well that's,
this isn't
Instagram post. Like, this isn't even
just on her website that maybe, you know,
if you're really interested
in Jada Pinkett Smith,
you're going to go and she's
all talking about wellness.
Like this is fucking insane. Do you think
that, um, she bust this out when, uh,
oh my gosh. What'd you think when will's
like a, uh, my new movie I just shot,
you know, it was a, that's coming out next
month. I'm pretty excited by, she's like,
check out what I just shot.
Yeah, it'd be great if this was on
her Instagram. And then what fought,
the next thing you clicked on was,
this is a story all
about how am I gonna fit?
This is beautiful where she is
so much beauty there and we should all
just look at how we're compromising
ourselves and our lives compromising
our happiness simply to not be alone.
Sounds like you used to love
and here's to you. Oh boy.
Sounds like there's troubling
marriage. You know what I mean? She's
like compromising myself, not happy. Hey,
when people take that tone because you
know they're lying and they don't believe
themselves. Sorry. Yeah. Oh, ah.
You guys been working on a lot and I
feel great and I don't have to, it's,
it's fine. Yeah. That's
horse shit. Oh yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah. You think that
like, a lot of this is just, um,
it's just directed at, you know,
one person and everything is like,
it's meant to be like this
is public consumption. I'm
just putting it out there.
But yeah, I'm really just
trying to tell you something.
I think so that's kind of my
favorite stuff. You're like,
this isn't for everybody.
So you have two options, right?
I can go home and be like,
I fucking did everything for you.
Or you can find a desert and be like,
I've put everything on the line.
Um,
I've been picked on a lot on this show.
I don't believe that I have
been for what I laugh at.
People think it's really wrong.
Sometimes Chad,
I'd agree with that statement,
but he gets picked on for laughing.
Laughs it inappropriate shit. Both. Okay.
Yeah, that's true. That's true
statement. Here's a submission.
Do you think this is
okay?
Funny. That's good. Now I
like where it's going already.
I know for a fact that I saw it though.
There was no question about that.
Rather read time now.
Then fucking retire.
Big Old fish breaks meal
for people listening.
Guy Who's a fishing, great
forearms, great forum.
Veiny probably just has those
natural strong forearms, you know,
just, yeah, he, he lives in
outdoorsman. Yeah. Lean, lean, build.
Um, so he's uh, getting
his, what do you call that?
His uncle bedded lure is lord or he's,
you know,
he's sitting there alone on
a boat. Um, fishing and yeah.
I don't know,
like to see,
get book,
fuck,
fuck.
Which has happened, which
is Hornet. Hornet stung him
a bunch of times. Uh, yeah,
I think a couple of maybe.
Wow.
It's a nice way to get
the fuck isn't nice.
God Damn God fucking damn boy.
Yeah. Kind of freaked out. Yeah. Yeah.
Ah, her fucking hearse. Gosh,
he was just so fun for so long.
Yeah, he was. He actually wrote in,
we rarely get the person who made
the video and send in the video.
Usually somebody else sending it in.
He goes,
I recently found your channel
understanding you like
videos of people getting
hurt.
So here you go.
I personally don't find it funny because
it happened to me, but all my pieces,
shit, quote friends seem to enjoy
me screaming like a bitch. Craig.
Well Craig, I did enjoy it.
Absolutely fantastic. Yeah.
Cause he said I'm going to
get this fee. Like, you know,
the big strategy behind it. Yeah.
And then all of a sudden attack mode.
And you thought that was funny. I
picked up like a prairie dog. Yeah.
I have the worst posture and all
of a sudden I was like, what?
Like I'm in the military
trying to watch that shit. Um,
but do you laugh at like things
like that? Absolutely. You do.
Now you guys are besties.
That's what I, yeah, yeah, sure.
Oh,
I better do something
that grounds coming pretty fast.
You heard it?
Yeah.
Why did you launch it?
Took it hard.
Oh God.
Ah,
yeah. You heard that shit crunch
that was coming status coming.
Really what it how funny is
it on a scale of one to five,
five being you very much agree.
Can you go through all of the numbers?
Just good.
Three being moderately agree.
I think if you jump out of a plane and
something bad happens to you. Yeah. Yeah.
Then that should be, oh,
here comes another one.
What was that?
Oh well that's straight up a car
was Bakula stuck.
Looked it up,
send it in.
Yeah.
That guy is that his son's hit the back
window. Right. I don't know. It's so,
these were real concerned though. I
was like, God damn, I slept in my car.
Yes. What though? We played this
so many times, so we've really gotten
it out there. It happened in Taiwan.
It turns out, because some people
were like, that guy's definitely,
his legs are removed.
He was fine.
He was actually really, yeah.
This was in the news there.
Guide turned out to be totally fine. He's
bruised, but it definitely looked worse.
Yeah. It looked like he was going
to get a lot of that amputee. Yeah.
Divo t emails. Uh, yeah.
Is that funny for you to, I mean, don't
stand behind the car I have. It's,
it's all this common sense
shit. Yeah. Right. Yeah.
That's a, that's, that's true.
That's a different perspective.
People always make fun of me
because when I walk into a bathroom,
I always look behind the door.
If I'm at a bar,
I peeked behind the door just because of
my friends are like, what are you doing?
I'm like, wow, that's
not gonna be so funny.
When you get butt fucked in
here but I'm not going to, yeah,
you're a part of that.
The rape culture.
You're afraid of a kind of how
women have to deal with the world.
Do you navigate the world the way we do?
Okay.
Well I just like to know what's behind
the door that way went I'm cause we don't
have to question it. Right. You
know, we do that to someone in here.
We're going to fucking
attack me right here.
Makes lot of sense in here.
In this house especially. No,
no one's going to, you're fine. Right. Um,
no tune tune.
This is my heartbeat tuned to
me. Takes that long. That long.
That slow. Yeah. Have you been,
have you had it checked out? Really?
You kind of like a problem when
I sleep people think I'm dead.
You should probably have it looked at,
you know,
they can just do like a sonogram of it.
Cause my mom had some heart defects.
They checked mine and make sure
I didn't have it. I don't anyway,
they just put a thing over it to do
quick, quick. They can look at it.
I just think it's cause I don't know how
to love if you guys have not yet been
convinced to see Chad
or guessing not so funny
today you have been,
if you have not yet been convinced to
see him live, uh, we highly recommend it.
But we also think you might be convinced
by the web stuff he's been doing.
No.
When I say I don't work,
I only mean that I ended regular
full time employment at age 40.
Since those like me who are on disability
don't seem to need it. I'll explain.
Oh boy.
Highly intelligent.
I was born with physical problems and
severe learning disability that got worse
with time.
What the fuck is this? I was just trying
to explain where I was at that day.
Yeah,
it's a cool backdrop.
I kind of feel like a map of the,
and a a symbol.
Um,
some might say is a swastika.
Just thought that was here.
Like wind power. Oh No, I just
letting people know where you stand.
Can I tell you something? I
don't even know what it, what
is about to happen? Yeah.
My, my why Mh tinglies are
telling me this is going,
this might be something we're going
to enjoy for, for weeks to come. Yeah.
You might be right feeling like
it's got the makings of a video.
This is a,
okay.
So the person who made this just in case
you didn't know is not chat if you're
listening. Um, but they,
they have, uh, they have,
um, uh, a little screen. I
can't even think of words.
I'm an announcement at the top of the
show of his videos that say I'm hosting
this channel as an extremely controversial
speaker. Ooh, that's what the,
that's what it says before these
videos play. And as a citizen,
the U S I uphold the freedom of speech
that our constitution provides says that
freedom of speech is meant
to protect unpopular speech.
So this guy is really a free
speech proponent when he's
done his research. Yeah.
It also says that the man
has some mental difficulties.
He might,
well that's good to them.
He says he might inadvertently offend
or invite dismissal by being socially
inept and to overlook it instead,
investigate his claims and viewpoints
for yourself. So it's just,
no one's just an asshole anymore.
I know. It's always like prefacing,
it is like Patrick Ewing.
Well,
my finger hurts just in case I don't have
a great game. I think there's a right,
there's, there's um, so much here that
I'm just going to jump through a few.
Let's go. I just want to see
what he's, what he's up to.
I could only graduate high school via
a special program for problem students.
I didn't go to college since Snow College
could accommodate my needs. From there,
I worked many jobs.
Could only secure very low paying jobs.
Half the time I couldn't even find work.
Even the low paying job until my
father stepped in for me. For example,
one time my father gave my
manager money for Christmas.
One company hired me because my
father's company was funding.
There's a boss from another company
hired me because it's trialed.
Was enrolled at my father's
daycare center. Oh, Katherine.
My Dad retired from full time work.
He told some security companies
that if they hired me.
Okay. That's a lot. There's
a lot. I like the cadence.
It's a kind of Wisconsin eat
cadence, right? Ooh, I don't
know. I think it's more,
uh, it sounds more Amish.
You think so? Yeah.
Like a Philadelphia, Pennsylvania. Oh,
I thought it was more Midwest. Okay.
I like that he talks like that. I like
his background. I like his presentation.
Let's see if he pushes any buttons.
Suffering right now.
I don't know if he pushes any buttons.
Let's see.
Occasions of mystery and
discrimination. Oh, for instance,
I was fired for supposedly attaching and
raising the American flag upside down
on the flag pole,
which I never do while he recent Muslim
immigrant from another shift had the
same job and it was
likely to have done it.
Wow. Oh my muscles don't have to
stress. That is a sign of distress.
When you raise the flag upside down.
It's a sign of distress.
I learned that from a Robert Redford.
Really?
Yeah. You remember the movie? Maybe
it's something to do with castle.
Ah, okay. Maybe it was just the castle,
but it was also the guy from Sopranos.
James Gandolfini. Yeah. Who
was the prison warden. Anyways,
but so I want to go back here.
This guy has a manager and his dad
has a company and a daycare that funds
another company, but yeah, that and
then he goes, but my dad's daycare.
Yeah. Maybe his dad had multiple,
a lot of confusing shit going on.
Yep.
The company I work at,
the longest fellow employees
kept purposely blowing big farts,
which I had to smell and breathe.
There it is. So there it is.
I knew I was going to like it.
He might be talking about
me. Yeah. What Jim does,
he need to likeness.
I was working security at another job.
I found a sweater of blood.
It was a freak accidents where somebody
collapse right in the middle of a tiny
staircase, which I couldn't
find in time. Therefore,
they tried to blame me for trying to
murder someone. Believe it or not.
So far. This guy's got your number
blowing farts. Yup. Murdering people.
That's the first time he looked
off the paper to just say,
let's just raise his hands up.
Can you believe this?
I have not murdered anyone. A blowout
fights. Not. I haven't. Not yet.
We got to ask him ride or die.
Okay.
Oh,
so for those who complained that I'm
cheating the governor match McCain.
You don't know anything. This,
you didn't like me. You think?
Oh judge others until I explain myself.
Today is a mental illness day.
I know mom's mental health awareness
last week. Oh, well, there you go.
That's why we're doing this.
That is it just a little late.
This guy should have to read everything
because that keeps him calm. Yeah.
And then my dad had my manager.
Why are you doing that was so
scary. Yeah, that's aggressive.
I liked it. Yeah. I like
the why are you doing this?
And I like the blowing farts part. Yup.
He's hurt someone. Yeah. Yeah. Absolutely.
He's done big farts. Yeah. Ghana. Yeah,
man. It's a lot going on in that
club. We're going to have to, yeah,
a few more times. I feel like we're going
to visit that again. It's a lot of it.
I accidentally overdosed.
Yeah.
Ah, yeah. Wow. I
accidentally overdosed. Yeah,
that's a lot, huh? Yup.
World is a special place.
It seems weird that that kind of guy
would have a hammer hanging on his wall
right by the door.
Oh,
you want to lead a pizza guy
just holding the hammer weigh up.
What do you think the justification is?
Like if somebody goes,
what's up with the swastika?
Do you think he has?
He probably has something like that.
I go,
he goes, it's not the fucking
hammer. What's up with the swastika?
I'll show you don.
I got get world map is where he's buried.
People.
One of those guys who does the,
uh, it's like the, you know,
the old white guy who goes,
how come I can't say the n word?
They say it all the time and you're like,
that's not how it works.
He's a liquid that's there. They're
like, it's perfectly logical.
Other people are saying it. Why can I see
it? It's always like a, and you go like,
you, here's the thing. I don't have
to tell you like, you know why?
You know why you're not supposed to
say it. You know what I mean? Like,
but why can't we go? Yeah. You
go like, why can't you go, ew,
I you don't need the explanation.
This is just like kind of a theatrical
thing you're doing and it's the same guy
who would be like, I have a swastika.
And you're like, why would you do that?
They're like, well, you know what,
actually the symbol existed
before the [inaudible].
So I am a of the belief that we should
celebrate the old Egyptian interpretation
of this Watson Native American.
Yeah. Yeah. You're like, oh,
so you overlook the people that
kind of misused it. Exactly.
Since then they've used it for other
things. Yeah. Have you heard about this?
Famous for just to be clear,
I'm using it for something else.
So be, be free to interpret
it as you choose. Anyways,
that's how I was feeling about the
confederate flag. That's another one.
It's all these guys are like,
we shouldn't be,
we shouldn't be given participation
ribbons to kids and it's like,
well that's what the fucking confederate
flag is when that's a participation
ribbon.
That's true.
And they keep it in their trucks with
their nuts on the trucks. It's, yeah,
it's nuts. Yeah. In California.
Not In southern California.
Yeah, true tread here, man. Oh,
see so much fucking road Beave down in
the Osi. I'm looking for road beef, man.
It's just a lot of,
then you got a text and it's a homeless.
I'm just lazy.
Yeah.
Um,
I recently moved in with my grandmother
who was an email with my grandmother
after graduating college.
I found myself in a great dilemma.
I get up every morning and get ready
for work and like any reasonable human
being,
I take a pre work poop 8:15 AM is my time
just like the great top dog and I have
found myself in a great deal of trouble.
You've heard of pissing on the seats,
I presume? Well, Hal about shitting on
the seat. Yes. You read that, right?
My grandmother shits on the seat every
morning. Oh, and I don't know what to do.
Is this a power play by her?
Is this a way of communication?
Should I leave her some brown as a
message back? Anyway, Tommy and Tina,
the real question is,
should I become poop pals
with my grandmother instead
of pen pals with her piss
on me, beat me, Yada Yada, Yada.
Ding, Ding. You know the drill Jacob?
I think your grandmother, I don't know
where to begin is begging you to leave.
Absolutely. She's just like, I was being
nice when I said you could come
live with me. You piece of shit
on the seat or not. I think it's
right on the back of the seat.
That's probably what's going on when
people sit back too far. Yeah, exactly.
And you know and it like
skims all the way down.
So like your shit is flat on her ass
hole is probably on right by right now.
Chad. I thought I heard it all. Yeah,
we talk about Brown a lot on this show.
Do I have never heard this tassel is
probably right up against the back room
dude. I never even thought
because he blew my mind.
It might be because of how old she is.
She's sitting,
you know one of those things, those
workers, maybe a bad back legs.
You don't know.
And if you're not using the squatty potty
[inaudible] sometimes it can curl up
and go back. But imagine you finding
that shit every morning, every morning.
Then you're like, God dammit,
there's shit all over the seat.
If that isn't motivation to get your
own place, I dunno what is, yeah,
that's going to be us.
And 30,
40 years shitting on the love
that you gave it that long.
Do you think the next week you started
sitting on seats, you will, I'll be like,
fucking Tommy Shit on this thing.
I know he's gonna put me in the
home right away. It'd be like, no,
I'll clean your shit. Ah, yeah, this
is your new place. And I'm like, wow,
do you like it here babe? I'm like, ah,
that'd be nice to you. I'll be the
guy who was like, go on another bath.
They give me another bath. I'm
like, it's still dirty down here.
My grandma had dementia and w I'd always
go eat dinner with her when I was in
town and a weight that was at a
retirement center in Minnesota. Yeah.
And so she would,
uh,
we ate one day and then they
cleared the plates and she goes,
when are we going to eat? And I
go, don't you feel full? Let me,
can't you like nothing. You know, I try,
I try to understand, but for me, I'm like,
we just fucking eight and then I go,
we'll try to remember what you ate.
Do you have any idea? And she was
like, I don't, but I, I trust you.
And then we wouldn't watch checks or
Texas Walker Ranger or whatever that's
called Walker, Texas. Yeah. And,
uh, but 10 minutes later she goes,
and she looked at me, she goes, Spaghetti.
No. I was like, well, what
the fuck? That's pretty great.
Yeah. She tasted it. I said,
wow. That's how she remembers. She has
to get it back up. Oh my gosh. Wow.
That's actually a really sweet story.
It is.
Was there a long time ago?
Uh, yeah. Yeah. For four years
ago. Not that long ago. She, is,
she still with us? She's not Spaghetti
Spaghetti's gone spaghetti got her.
Do you have any other grandparents left?
[inaudible] parents. I'm wiped out. Yeah.
My mom. Your mom? Yeah. You close
to her? Yeah, I live, uh, I dunno.
Two miles away.
The are you serious? That's,
that's kind of Nice. That's sweet.
I see my parents twice a year.
Oh, you know what? We
live 2,500 miles from me.
I see my mom twice a year really
to fucking miles and really well,
I'm more than that, but not as much
as I probably should. Yeah. But she's
retiring October 26 so she said,
I'll be over for coffee every morning.
And I was like, great. I'm moving.
My Dad retiring December 3rd
and we've talked about it a lot.
I'm worried.
I'm serious.
He's been involved with stuff his
whole life and he's like, next chapter,
I don't know what I'm gonna do.
I'm like, fuck, stop saying that.
I don't know he's going to do. And I'm
like, well, you go off. He's like, yeah,
I'm not interested in anymore.
Like you're fucking lost interest in golf.
We you supposed to do now. Oh yeah.
I don't know what he's going to do.
That's not good. I know.
He's like fishing. I go,
you don't seem like the guy with
the patients for fishing. Yeah.
I'll get into it and then he
goes fishing with like uh,
my nephew next day. He was like, it
was terrible. It's three hours after.
I'm like three hours isn't even that long.
I've seen this happen.
You know where it ends? Where
Spaghetti. Spaghetti. Yeah. Fuck.
I want him to get involved
in something which we get.
I don't know anything that's going to
make those videos. Have my dad make bit,
make some videos with stuff on the wall.
I maybe I might have to get him
more involved in the podcasts.
Maybe like we talked about having him.
Why don't we do movie reviews?
We were talking about having to do it
cause he loves to go to the movies.
He told me the other day, he's
like, you know what's a great movie?
It's a movie that's out. And
I go okay. And he's like,
you can always tell it's a good movie
cause your mother and I both liked it and
I go, yeah, that's my criteria too.
Like, as long as youtube both like it,
then I know it's a good movie.
He's convinced that other people will
always line up with his perspective on
movies.
It's the,
he walks out of whatever the number
one movie is like every other month.
And he's like, I went and saw
this thing. It was terrible. Like,
I think that's the number one movie in
the world right now. He's like, yeah,
it's not good. I'm like, okay.
And he's just out of their splits
all the time. What's your mom?
What did she retiring
from? Uh, she is, uh,
like the marketing receptionist
for a power company. Okay.
Yeah. So she's just ready to get the
fuck. I was just super stoked. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. I think my dad is too. I
just wish you had like the, uh,
the other exciting interest he lives in.
Where Florida. Yeah, I'd like to see him,
man on the streets situation
interviewing millennials. I'm like,
God, this might be a good
idea. Check grade now.
He loves a current current events.
Quizzes at dinner.
It's one of his favorite games.
That'd be great. Yeah. Yeah. Well,
he likes to humiliate your sisters. Yes.
How little they know about the world.
That's actually, and his goal. He's
just like broads, don't know as much.
Yeah, he does. He does. He's like,
now let me ask you something.
Who was the secretary of state?
And like, if they're like, I don't know.
He's like, yeah, loves it. Loves it.
That they don't know.
It's like so old school,
but he really is thrilled that
a girl doesn't know. I know he
loves to bring up politics
with me. [inaudible] every
time we talk now, Christina,
are you happy that the supreme court
is made of old white guys? Yeah.
And I'm like, yes. Talk to. I know what
happened with Kevin on none of that. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. He's very
much into that. Yeah.
You gotta know what the MPF on
sites to bait me. Ah, yeah. Yeah.
We'd have to edit the fuck out
of it, but yeah, he'd be like,
here is a six hour real. All
right. We are talking to people.
One interview a person. Jesus, man. Yeah,
the movie thing would be fun. Yeah. Well,
I've always wanted my mom to review, uh,
hip hop albums ever listened and that
would be great. And then have her say,
dummy, this is disgusting. Yeah.
Yeah. Maybe not the whole album.
Maybe like one song. Yeah. What do
you think of the song? Yeah, whatever.
Like the number one song is on the charts.
Yeah.
It could be fun and it probably sounds
like this. Get it, flip it, suck it. Yeah,
exactly. That's about right. That's all
my daughter's listening to you, right?
Is that, yeah. I feel like
music, I mean I listen,
I'm an old fogy I listened to
same shit I like when I was 15.
I'm not a good music current music person,
but I do feel like it has gone that way.
Right?
Like I watched the vms on MTV and I
looked up the acts and I'm like, dude,
all this shit's a exactly the same.
It's like mall music. Yeah. It's a,
so she listens to that around the house.
It will be like, do the dishes, vacuum.
That's like all that.
Yeah. All that stuff.
And then she plays her Ukulele
and she'll play, you know,
like where is my mind or something by
then. Oh, cool. Yeah. So it's like,
where are you learning this? Well, we
share iTunes and it's all your stove.
Oh. So she gets to learns
it on Ukulele and then,
but the music she listens to, it's
ridiculous. I have a question.
How long ago did you stop recording?
Oh No, we're still going. Actually looked.
I thought you'd just be like
Spaghetti. Huh? That's the fights.
And that's on the phone.
Here's my dad laughing at his own
Joe cupcake.
It's like
mock the book.
What's the high pitch?
Sorry. That is not yet out. Yeah.
Multiple choice questions.
You sound,
are you okay? All right.
So that's so funny.
I can't believe I'm blanking on the front.
It sounds like someone's laughing
in the background. A female. Yeah,
that's him completely losing his shit.
And this is my mom.
I'm chattel.
I'm Polly and buy and you can call me z
and making her do reads.
I love how you're introducing
me to all your fit.
Like you're auditioning me to be your
brother. I want you to be my brother.
This is my dad. This is a good idea. Okay.
If you have never up, I'm fine.
But at the same time, can you even
that Julia I own,
are you the double pipe closet?
Yeah.
So those two are going to
be locked in a home together
for the next however long
they live. Jesus, man,
I think it's going to be crazy.
I really do. I'm worried.
I wish them both the best of luck.
Why don't you have him come
here and live with you guys.
Let's see what else is going on.
Uh,
um, Chadwick was your
birth name, right? Sure.
Chattels Chattels Chattels Matthew.
Yeah,
I can tell you anything about me
cause I've had lifelock since I was,
since it came out cause my dad stole my
identity. He did? Yeah. So I was like,
well if he's going to do
with maybe a stranger,
will you tell us the story please? He
just a, I don't know. He, he needed a,
so he went to prison for check
fraud, all sorts of stuff. Yeah.
I did not know any of this about you.
Yeah. He went to prison and then, uh,
then he took off to Los Vicky actually.
So I bought a car.
There was something wrong with the engine.
They gave me a replacement car to drive.
Then my dad made copies of the
keys and when I got my car back,
had me drive him to the dealership,
stole that car and drove it to Las Vegas.
Wow.
What? Yeah. And my mom, I couldn't tell
my mom any of that stuff. So she was like,
I just want your kids to know it's
not your fault. And I was lying.
Well, Kinda no shear. How
old were you? I was, uh,
probably 19 at the time. Did you, did you,
what was your perspective on him
then? Well, I just thought, you know,
he's a fucking lunatic. You did? Yeah.
So if he's going to la, he's like,
I'm going to Las Vegas. Like,
great. Yeah. That's horrible.
But it's, uh, you know,
uh, Chad, Steven Katz.
Stephen Daniels. Yeah. Is that
your dad's name? It is, yeah.
My piece of shit. Huh? Pretty Great.
I don't know why you're all over him.
Yeah.
What's your fucking problem?
Wow. Right. Just it's my dad.
I loved him. You find it,
cause my parents were kind of
wacky too. As a parent. Did you,
I don't know, like do you
not know how to, what,
what a good dad looks like cause
you're just kind of shitty? No,
I think I go from the opposite.
I know what not to do.
Does that make sense? Yeah.
So I'm not always doing the right thing,
but I,
I was given a checklist of what not to do
at the beginning, so that helps. Right.
I looked at their birth
certificate and I thought,
well I'm never going to take this social
security number, use it to my advantage.
Right.
Interesting.
Yeah. Yeah. I know you're talking about,
cause I tried to get a phone
and I tried to get just fuck,
I went to get a car and the guy
for financing and the guy was like,
um, it says here you owe $40,000 in
child support on your credit report.
I was like, alright,
how do you, how do you,
you know, beat that? Like how do you
overcome that? Like in real life?
Like, what's, what's the
process like when you go, oh,
everyone thinks I'm somebody. Like I went
through this phase of killing animals.
I would, uh, pray over their
body for their soul and like,
thank you for that. Did that make your
life terrible? Killing animals? No.
Know What Your Dad did? No, not
really. No. I mean it was a credit.
I think Tom's asking, you know,
you just have to call and say like,
I was living with my mom the entire time.
I didn't have this apartment.
I didn't have, don't they not
believe you? They don't believe you,
but so you just have to get the records.
And which is it a hassle for you?
A bit of a hassle. Sure. Yeah.
My mom would take my,
my social security number as a teenager,
as I was like 15 years old and
open credit lines, credit cards.
One time I checked my credit
accounts open that I didn't even,
was it to build your credit though?
No,
there's so she could credit cards
because my stepdad had ruined her credit
because he was a criminal. Oh,
can I, can I tell you something?
Your mom stole your identity,
you know that, right? Okay. No,
I'm telling my therapist that
justify it and I'm like, no,
that's straight up theft.
It's happened.
It's a good therapist for
your daddy issues or, uh,
I ha when I went through my divorce,
I saw a therapist and a minister,
but I'm not religious, but it was just
nice to, uh, to chat two times a week.
That's awesome. Yeah. I would go
every day if I could have helped a ton
because they have, you
know, you're like, well,
why do I think this and
why do I think this?
And then he draws a little diagram
and you're like, oh, all right.
That makes total sense.
That helps a lot of shit.
I thought I was a crazy person and I
didn't want to be near my kids because it
might hurt them. No, that's not true.
But you, how long did you see them for?
I probably saw all sudden done
by two years. Wow. That's great.
That's awesome. I feel
much better. I do not.
Sometimes I go now I'll go like once
every four months cause I'll be like, ah,
I'm fucking this,
this thing sucks.
Better call that guy and then I can't
get in for 10 days and then I get there
and I'm like, it's all fixed. So
you want to grab lunch? Yeah. Yeah.
I go every week. So. Okay. For uh, uh,
to see a therapist. I mean
for what? Let's talk about it.
Just whatever's on my mind.
I didn't have like a big jump off thing.
I just feel my oil change. Right? Yeah.
It feels like a d scrambling your mind.
So the way I feel like it,
like you go in there like I'm all
fucking fixated on this thing.
And then sometimes like the person can
just say two sentences to you and you're
like, yeah, I should just chill the
fuck out. You ever picked it or not?
Yeah. Forever. And the more it gets
tighter and your fucking frustrated yeah.
And then you just need
that one person to go,
you're pulling on the wrong side or
whatever. It kind of feels like that.
Yeah. I'm a big, big fan of it.
I really encourage people
to go as often as possible.
I'm trying to tell you to make more
appointments and keep going. Yeah,
I don't think I'm, I think
I'm fucking fine. All right.
Go See Christina.
Do stand ups now we're talking
Plugin Christina's act.
Cool.
It's really neat
about in therapy. Well, I
make my mom say all this shit.
All right. Um, okay. Uh, Chad, Kathy,
thank you for stopping by for having me.
We have a lot of fun with you.
People can see you if you're listening.
The moment this comes out,
don't forget that Wednesday night you
could see Chad at the Irvine Improv the
rest of the weekend in Tempe at the Improv
there and any other big dates coming
up. I will just leave it at
that. Okay. And their website
I carried, but Chad daniels.com
all my live dates are till
march. Okay. On there. So you can
everything he's put out, it's amazing.
Checkout his album specials will
be another one. You guys, I mean,
could you tell from what I
was saying today? Yamahan
try it out by Freddy and the cat closing
song. Thank you guys for listening.
We'll see you next [inaudible]
lack God's love. The fucking fuck. Look,
if you're a hot black guy and you want
to fuck me at 2195 this is one a move and
you can move in and you're
going to fucking have any,
I need to be fucked a lot
right.